straßenbahn technologie für den lkw bald
könnten über oberleitung mit strom
versorgte lkw unserer autobahnen
bereichern mehr dazu jetzt bei klicks
und varna wuchsen im norden von berlin
entsteht sensationelles beziehungsweise
ist schon sensationell es entstanden
dort kann eine rund zwei kilometer lange
highway lkw strecke bestaunt werden die
wie highway ermöglicht es lastkraftwagen
über ein typisches oberleitungen
systemen dafür ja schon lange zeit aus
dem bereich des bahnverkehrs kennen fast
ohne jeglichen fossilen treibstoff von a
nach b zu bringen in einer
pressemitteilung von der bundesregierung
heißt wird dazu die zwei kilometer lange
teststrecke mit oberleitungen die mehr
als fünf meter über der fahrbahn
installiert sind ist teil des vom
bundesumweltministerium geförderten
projekt in juba elektromobilität bei
schweren nutzfahrzeugen zur
umweltentlastung von ballungsräumen
federführend ist die siemens ag
wissenschaftlich begleitet wird das
projekt von der fakultät
verkehrswissenschaften der technischen
universität bremen beteiligt sind
darüber hinaus die automobilfirmen volvo
und scania peter ende
warum oberleitung warum nicht einfach
das von funktionierende konzept von pkw
wieder verwenden
anders als bei pkw könne man nicht auf
akku betriebene lkw setzen dass ich kein
lkw so lange an einem ort befinden würde
um den energiespeicher ausreichend
aufladen zu können
da der schwerlastverkehr einer studie
des bundesumweltamtes zufolge maßgeblich
am ausstoß der sogenannten
treibhausgasen beteiligt ist muss sich
schleunigst etwas ändern
siemens würde das system ermöglichen den
verbrauch fossiler kraftstoffe sowie die
betriebskosten der lkw deutlich zu
reduzieren und lokale emissionen co2 und
stickoxide zu eliminieren
dabei gibt es ein ähnliches system schon
lange das erste testfahrzeug war achtung
bereits 882 unterwegs und auch eine
erfindung von siemens genau von werner
von demand dem gründer von wind und
wetter 52 gibt es ein oberleitungsbusse
metz kurz opnet im bowling darf immer
noch in betrieb ist und sicher eine
große zukunft vor sich hat ein großer
schritt in die richtige richtung würde
ich mal sagen und das ist eure meinung
dazu ist die straßenbahn technologie bzw
die obus technologie auf den lkw betrieb
umsetzbar oder nicht kann man das auf
autobahnen machen wenn also bald
elektrische lkw über die autobahnen
brettern schreibt es mir in die
kommentare
und wenn euch das video gefallen hat
vergesst nicht genau dafür einen daumen
nach oben und nach wirklichen ein
kostenloses abo und hier gibts auch das
nächste video ansonsten würde ich sagen
bislang bleibt